I think so far Google to a friend of pre
culture their business model as it turns
out has been promised on openness and on
letting people basically do what they
want to do the fact that you can use
gmail is a file storage system because
you just given so many free gigabytes as
an example of that but Google
applications like almost every other web
application development system is a
service rather than a product it is a
service offered to developers rather
than a one-time platform that lets you
launch your app into the welcoming arms
of a consuming public who happen to run
the platform for which the app was
written Google Apps means that if Google
doesn't want an app to run on its
platform anymore it could cut it off and
any lawyer worth his or her salt
consulting with Google would say well
you never know what's going to happen
you might as well reserve the right to
kill any app at any time for any reason
and so long as that is the terms of
service for those apps whether it's on
Facebook or Google or other platforms
you have a way to nip a generative
blossom in the bud that doesn't exist on
the PC kazaa could happen and ultimately
challenge the music industry to support
the itunes music store and later amazon
fully unprotected mp3 downloads for a
fee I'm confident that the music if she
would not have gotten into any of that
but for the fact that they were having
to compete against pirated versions of
their own songs and in that sense I
think because I was salutary even though
brazenly illegal many of its uses if you
can nip it in the bud under today's
application frameworks you would never
even have that cycle take place and I
would rather place my bets with the
unbridled programming environment
generating cool stuff then I would but
the much more controlled environment
where ultimately cool but initially
worried some stuff gets killed in its
release